thank you
[Music]
so we've kind of touched on this before
but there's a new update so we of course
have to bring the news fresh and ready
to all of our fans and supporters out
there all right fide aka the
international Chess Federation
says players who have transitioned from
male to female have quote no right to
participate in women's events until the
Federation conducts quote further
analysis and renders a final decision so
they have effectively banned transgender
women from competing in women's chess
events pending further analysis pissed
about this what's the sentiment are you
pissed yeah yeah you are your sentiment
don't you feel Injustice
um I'll say this I wouldn't imagine
there's a lot of transgender people
getting upset about this is there
could be that man that's his answer
we report the news here you need to take
a more solid state how do you feel as a
dude honestly I feel indifferent about
it is that bad to say why
you don't I'm not really attached I'm
not attached to the chat oh well I just
imagine like you don't think chess is a
sport do you chess is dope but isn't it
just like mental well here's not mental
but here's the question the inner gender
no and answer this do you believe
do you believe that men have an inherent
advantage over women at chess I wouldn't
imagine there would be no there is those
things there is yeah well I guess that's
why there's a oh so they do have
separate divisions yeah oh I didn't know
that for real is it because of
Statistics or if someone just said so no
it's actually a thing yeah really well
then yeah that's very simple but of I
think there's already an example of
someone coming in and identifying as a
female as a clear dude who yeah yeah it
wasn't even trans he just said he
identified but he got inside the
competition to prove the difference
between men and women playing chess as
far as yeah that's what I want to know
the advantage because when I hear that
no I wouldn't imagine there would be a
difference but if there's statistics
there's a statistical difference yeah my
question is what is the difference to
how did they even come up with the
difference like how is the study they
got more grooves in their brain like
when they have like co-ed tournaments so
it's it's always a dude that wins them
yeah but also um it's like you know how
they time that's what I'm thinking too I
think that's the same reason why less
women win darts right I think more dudes
just play [__] darts if you're a girl
that plays darts like most that's
probably hard to find like I don't know
so damn it was a hit because of that
though right she came in and rocked in
rocked like all the men who were
basically the dominating is that based
on a like a real story recorded history
of Chess World Champions have always
been male not female further there is
currently only one woman in the top 100
chess players in the world so I think
she now identifies as a man so really
I don't know if it's a
um like they found it yeah I don't think
there is the results that where they're
the Dom where the dominance is it's just
not not because it's like proven like oh
uh men are just better at so logic and
strategy games so this is the system
they created the ratio yeah yeah for for
the most part most women don't play
right apparently according to different
types of articles that I'm not citing
specifically uh males dominate the
chesting and ranking in population but
not because they are just more
intelligent in that sense instead the
influences that affect the imbalance in
chess demographics can be attributed to
biological psychological social economic
and cultural factors sure men design
chess for men historically chess was
dominated by men because it represented
a physical battle it was invented when
physical combat was commonplace in
warfaring countries men would strategize
and fight while women stayed at home
where it was safer there's chess and
boxing tournaments where they people box
and they play Chess at the same time
that's nuts it's a different part of
your brain yeah more males than females
play chess we've already talked about
that racially uh ratio racially uh
dominance in chess can mean more than
one thing while the numbers of
Statistics show male dominance in chess
dominance should be defined it doesn't
necessarily mean better it just means
there are more playing chess and females
however gender equality is causing a
shift in the demographic ratios
represented in chess I think the more
they do it it's just like gaming like in
video games there weren't as many good
girls but now that you know a lot of
girls are streaming and [__] you get to
see that there actually are more and
more every day like there's just better
the real answer is probably like
nobody's smarter than anyone is just
numbers based off of those things yeah I
don't know I think in this case I would
be okay if females sign up for the mail
competitions because there hasn't been a
like overwhelmingly
disadvantage on the on uh if a girl
comes through so then that's like she's
actually going up against odds whereas
like on the flip side he would have a
disadvantage like a a Advantage so that
he would be putting his opponents at a
disadvantage so that would be an unfair
advantage
um if a pro chess player comes in well I
think it'd just be like men and women at
the same ranking chess players should
play together yeah yeah yeah I guess
according to this like there hasn't been
females at the same rank until the pool
gets bigger and they can compete at the
same level so then yeah I think like
it's fair on the flip side if it's yeah
and then they have to have a track
record too so if they're just an amateur
like an amateur guy that doesn't even
play chess he should be able to sign up
because then he's gonna get dominated
yeah a transgender male or female should
just be able to enter why are they
Banning it
that's the way that's the way although
you could possibly be like if if we
don't ban this then it opens up the door
to like physical Sports and other things
and that conversation so yeah
um I don't know I don't know also maybe
maybe women don't want it maybe that
could because it's in their division a
big enough fight for the women too yeah
it's like with that thing that happened
where some guy uh said he was a woman
and he entered all women poker
tournament and just decimate everybody
it's like they but then the point was is
that the women have their own division
because they just want to do it by
themselves you know it's like that was
the whole point of making it it wasn't
that they were worse or better it was
just like we just don't want guys guying
up the place like they wanted a Girls
Club yeah it's like Fair cool you should
be able to have that if you want it but
then yeah if you do that then that's no
longer what they but that was more of
like a we created this thing it wasn't
like a tournament where it was like
ranked and it was for it was for a pot
it was it was like a tournament for
money as a prize but are you are you
allowed to do it on the flip side though
have like a gentleman's poker tournament
thing and it's no girls allowed or
whatever is that people do that all the
time yeah you just make it yeah
you just said no girls outside yeah yeah
just put a sign no girl's Allowed no
girls allowed there's a boys club Only
yeah
the national Center for transgender
equality and advocacy group based in the
U.S criticized the decision of course
they said really chess this is so
insulting to CIS women to trans women
into the game itself it assumes that
this woman couldn't be competitive
against this man and relies on ignorant
anti-trans ideas
well here's the thing is like I know
they have men's leagues and then women's
leagues now based on this article but do
they ever have a mixed League like how
does that what does that look like does
that happen I heard that that that makes
them
it's like insulting this is so because
they're like Nam like I'm just as man as
you are yeah you know and then it's like
so they don't want to be Special
Olympics because they don't see it as
like I'm not right that's fair because
in their in their head that's just a man
even if it's a transgender man it's like
I'm not even thinking I'm sorry I should
rephrase that I'm not even thinking
about it before the game just more of
like the actual sport like a
free-for-all like like do they do that
often where it's just a co-ed tournament
where it's men and women and they just
go and they just see well I think the
reason why there's a woman's league is
so that women can participate in the
sports or else they'll never be
allowed in it like they won't rank yeah
most sports in most yeah oh so you're
saying that if they just did a hey guy
girl whatever you are yeah you can all
enter I think that'll just end up with
all guys that's the problem it's like if
you just did hey everybody we're gonna
do dumb contests anyone you anybody's
available
things that are more mental like say
poker right because when they have the
World Series of Poker
are you chest poker as far as the mental
capacity well as far as like there's no
physical element right there's no okay I
don't have to box somebody out I'm like
dunk on anybody I mean like like as far
as like taller guys have an advantage
yeah yeah yeah like because when they do
the World Series of Poker it's co-ed no
it's like man yeah yeah yeah it is yeah
but there hasn't been but the final
table's still mostly guys oh I see this
no I'm pretty sure there's tournaments
where there are co-ways yeah players all
games are co-ed yeah because it's just
about the buy-in yeah but then there
there hasn't been a person yet like
female that's won the World Series for
sure but I think I think over time
that'll change right like yeah but I
would say I would argue is because
there's not a lot of women right right
right not because like women can't play
they have a different style of play and
I've played against solid female like
Nikki like she's a great player so it's
like yeah I think it's like it just
depends because in my head I'm like why
don't they just do that for chess
right I think that's the thing it's like
if they do that then statistically the
women will be knocked out way sooner and
that's fine but as time goes on right
then the maybe the as the popularity
grows and more women because I think
it's just more of a global exposure
thing it's like if more people play
chess and more people see like oh this
is an Avenue where I could do this and
it'll allow more people to be like oh
and maybe more women would be like oh
maybe I'll do this later in life I
thought the women's sports I thought
women sports and women's like leagues
and all that
it started because of women to protect
separate like yeah and it the whole
point was yeah for them to be able to
participate and enjoy it and have their
own leagues and all that
and I thought that yeah that was the
original like goal but then if you make
it all co-ed then it does make it so
they can well it's the difference
between that's true the mentality of a
sport and the physicality of a sport
right like so something like chess and
poker there's no physicality yeah
involved your face
my whole thing is like all right but
we're talking about like in comparison
to like football or soccer or something
you know because I think there's a world
where can all exists right men divisions
women divisions and then co-ed divisions
like because I'm sure there's some
gangster chicks that are like yo I want
to [__] compete against the boys I
want to see how good I am right right so
why not right yeah I just I think that's
an easy fix don't you think or am I just
tripping maybe it does it already exists
I think so one is just a anybody
division yeah I think they already exist
I think the conversation is now in a new
gray area of inclusivity to transgender
people or people who are identifying as
a specific one for sure yeah and I think
that conversation opens up the door to
other sports oh well other sports like
for example like this marathon is co-ed
uh Spartan Race like all those yeah yeah
they they don't but the thing is when
you're signing up for that you're
already choosing to sign up for the code
division now that the conversation is
what about the people who were born One
Way choosing to identify the other and
then going into that individual category
that's the difference
so that's that's why that's why for
example World Aquatics which we've
talked about here before as well has
recently launched a new open category
which will welcome swimmers of all sex
and gender identity in order to address
that particular thing where they also
voted to restrict the most transgender
athletes from competing in Elite women's
Aquatics competitions last year you know
what I'm saying so they're trying to
address the issue and as a result are
creating new spaces to allow this really
unique new not saying transgender is
like new but like the the conversation
about it and how it's at least in sports
exactly physically dominated Sports yeah
because we want fairness is a big Topic
in any type of sport right you want to
make sure that all platforms are fair to
a degree so yeah I think creating a new
division or a division for chess it's
like just do co-ed but that's that's the
touch the touchy part of it is as simple
as the bathrooms it's like if they're
saying we didn't want an all-gender
restroom we wanted to use the men's
restroom then what can you say right so
I don't know [__] tough [__] dude
foreign